[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros hoy en 5
minutos con nos acompaña tiki del valle
vicepresidenta senior tendencias
digitales para mastercard en américa
latina y el caribe señora del valle
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 hablemos sobre un estudio de
mastercard que revela que más de 40
millones de latinoamericanos fueron
bancarizados en los últimos 5 meses a
causa de esta pandemia de coronavirus y
se inclinaron por las finanzas digitales
restringiendo el uso de efectivo le
pregunta entonces señora del valle cuál
fue el impacto del cob y 19 en inclusión
financiera en la región
muchísimas gracias por la invitación
cuando el mundo entro en cuarentena
muchos gobiernos latinoamericanos
respondieron con subsidios para las
personas más vulnerables a través de
toda latinoamérica sin embargo aún
prevalece que el uso del efectivo de la
mitad de los latinoamericanos
desafortunadamente reciben sus pagos e
inmediatamente van a los cajeros
automáticos lo que hemos visto luego con
el pasar de la pandemia es como los
latinoamericanos han aprendido los
beneficios de la digitalización por lo
cual ahora se encuentran utilizando más
los fondos que están recibiendo mediante
los subsidios para hacer sus compras en
línea para pagar sus necesidades básicas
por lo cual ya estamos viendo como este
esta pandemia realmente ha llevado un
impacto positivo a la inclusión
financiera de todos en la región así es
que le pregunto entonces ahora cuáles
fueron esos disparadores para esta
inclusión
con el mate 70 de la penetración de
smartphones y el surgimiento de los
bancos digitales y de la finta américa
latina tiene una oportunidad increíble
donde están sin precedentes estamos
utilizando la digitalización para
transformar el estado de inclusión
financiera junto con el ecosistema de
los bancos de los gobiernos y de las
redes de tarjetas estamos convencidos
que la digitalización y la tecnología
pueden crear un impacto positivo en
en la sociedad si enfocamos nuestros
esfuerzos en modelos sostenibles modelos
que ayuden a las personas en la base de
la pirámide para de esa forma poder
llevarlos a esta inclusión financiera
usar no es no es suficiente preocuparnos
por proveer acceso a las personas con
nuevas tarjetas sino también debemos
enfocarnos en llevar el uso en llevar la
educación a estos consumidores así es
entonces ahora le pregunto cómo cambiar
nuestros hábitos de pago y consumo en
las personas con esta pandemia que
todavía vivimos
lo que hemos visto es como como como las
personas realmente han estado moviéndose
ya dos dado el impulso y el comercio
electrónico que vemos hoy en día hay más
de una tercera parte de los atrás de las
transacciones que vemos a nivel de
región ya son transacciones que se
realizan en línea así que estamos
mirando como los consumidores a través
de la pandemia se han han tomado ventaja
y han podido realizar sus compras y han
podido mantenerse comunicados con sus
bancos de manera digital así que el uso
de los de las aplicaciones el uso
encontrar nuevas formas de realizar sus
pagos pagos que son diarios o que son
necesarios para ellos subsistir se están
tornando mucho más en pagos que se
realizan de forma línea en forma digital
y yo pregunto entonces señora el valle
como afectaron nuestros programas
sociales para para esta inclusión
financiera digital
lohan los han impactado de manera muy
positiva entonces de si acaso estamos
viendo un 'once' overlay ninguna algo
positivo que está saliendo de esta
pandemia y la realidad es que estos
subsidios en algún momento se van a
acabar por tanto no queda queda como
compromiso de industria como tenemos que
trabajar en conjunto con bancos
tradicionales tanto con como ellos con
bancos tradicionales como hola fin text
para poder desarrollar nuevos sistemas
financieros nuevos nuevos casos de uso
para que estos consumidores continúen
siendo incluidos en el ecosistema
financiero por tanto no nos queda
trabajo por hacer en lo que no solamente
debemos enfocarnos en lo que ha pasado
en estos últimos meses sino cómo
aprovechamos este este movimiento a la
digitalización de una de una manera que
impacta el futuro así de señora del
valle muchísimas gracias entonces por
toda la información de esta manera
llegamos al final de cinco minutos con
por el día de hoy hasta pronto
[Música]